لقد كان أحد أكثر مقاطع الفيديو المرعبة التي
خرجت من إيران متظاهرًا
محاطًا بقوات النظام المسلحة يحاول
صدهم بإطلاق
طلقات سكين قبل أن يسقط على ركبتيه،
وظهر لاحقًا في العناية المركزة بالكاد
واعيًا مع والديه بجانبه.
كان لدي شريان مقطوع في ساقي، كان لدي
حوالي 200 طلقة خرطوش في جسدي، كنت مصابًا
بجروح خطيرة حتى بعد
استسلامي واعتقلوني،
وضربوني حوالي مائة مرة على
رأسي وباقي جسدي بالهراوات
أثناء نقلهم.  نقلوني إلى
المستشفى أطلقوا النار عليّ من
مسافة قريبة جدًا ببندقية ظنوا
أنني سأكون هناك لكن أشكان نجا
ومعه قصة رعب لا يمكن تصورها
كنت الرجل الذي مات
وأعيد إلى الحياة وأنا أتحدث  معك
لا يزال لدي 20 رصاصة خرطوش
في جسدي، لقد هرب من إيران، وهو الآن
رجل مطلوب مختبئ يتحدث
حصريًا إلى CNN حفاظًا على سلامته،
ولن يقول أين هو، لقد
خرجت من البلاد عبر
الجبال والصحاري بينما كنت
أنزف بشدة  وفي حالة سيئة للغاية،
توفيت عدة مرات قبل أن أخرج من
البلاد بينما كان يرقد في المستشفى
معلقًا على الحياة بخيط تم
اتهامه بالمحاربة وشن الحرب ضد
الله، وهي جريمة يعاقب عليها بالإعدام في
عملاء نظام الجمهورية الإسلامية.  داهمت هذا المستشفى
وسحبت أشكان إلى السجن كما أرى عندما يتم
نقل شخص ما من وحدة العناية المركزة مباشرة
إلى السجن، هذا نوع من
حكم الإعدام في السجن لقد مررت
بعذاب لا يطاق لأن كل جروحي
كانت مفتوحة، استخدمت الملح لمحاولة
تطهير جسدي  كانت الجروح
تعذبني بشدة، وأرسلوني إلى
مستشفى تابع للجيش لم يكن مجهزًا
لعلاجي، وكنت هناك في تلك
الحالة ويداي
وقدماي مقيدتان بالسرير، واحتج
الأجانب
في مدينته الكردية
سنندس على رحيله.  أطلق سراح عائلته
ودفع كل ما لديهم لإنقاذه من
العلاج الطبي وبمساعدة
الأصدقاء تمكن من الخروج من إيران.
كنت ملاكمًا محترفًا ومقاتلًا
وكنت حريصًا جدًا على مستقبلي وكان لدي
خطة لمتابعة هذه الرياضة كلاعب.  مسيرتي المهنية
ولكن لأن ساقي وبقية
جسدي أصيبت بجروح بالغة، لا أستطيع
فعل ذلك بعد الآن،
أوه،
كوني بعيدًا عن عائلتي وكل
الضغوط التي تحملوها
بسببي تعذبني عقليًا، لا
أشعر أنني بخير جسديًا  أو عقليًا
ماذا تريد أن يعرف العالم عما
يحدث داخل إيران الآن
أنا آسف يا رجل حسن، هناك الكثير
مثلي ممن ضحوا بحياتهم للأسف ولكن
أصواتهم لم تصل إلى الخارج،
هناك الكثير من الفتيات الشجاعات و  الأولاد داخل
إيران بكاءنا الوحيد هو أننا نطالب
بالحرية والديمقراطية ونريد أن
تكون نسائنا مساوية لرجالنا صرخنا
حياة المرأة حرية وردهم علينا ما هو
إلا رصاصة فقط تعذيب
السجناء المغتصبين
رأيت العديد من الشباب 16 17 سنة
يتعرضون  لقد قتلوا لقد قتلوا الكثير
وأصابوا الكثير من العمى أقسم بالله أنني لا أستطيع
النوم ليلاً وأفكر في تلك
الأشياء
دون رادع بمجرد تعافيه
ويقول إنه مستعد للعودة ومواصلة
القتال من أجل حرية إيران.
لست نادماً وأنا كذلك.  فخور بما
فعلته، سأبذل حياتي من أجل شعبي
من أجل إيران، ليس مرة واحدة بل مائة
ألف مرة